in lecture on pcb theorem given by dana
she will talk about optimal inner
proxima
in approximability in particular
thank you okay so yeah so this is the
last talk
we'll talk about how to prove kind of
really
fine sharp
inner proximability thresholds
and in this talk it will finally be
clear kind of the depth
of the of the connection between pcp and
boxability and
geometry um it's a very very tight and
interesting connection
okay so let me let me start with that uh
so so what's what's the connection the
connection
is uh that uh the
best known algorithms for many many
combinatorial optimization problems
are geometric algorithms okay so it's
not true for all problems
it is true for very wide families of uh
of problems um so let me
give you as the running example we'll do
max cart
so max cut is the following problem it
was mentioned before by
it you're given a graph
and you're trying to find a cut in the
graph so a partition of the vertices
into two
such that there are many many edges
that that cause the cut so so one end
point of the edge is on one side and the
other end point is on the other side
it's very simple a combinator
optimization problem
um i want to tell you about the the best
algorithm we have for for max cut
which is which is purely geometric uh
this is the gorman's williamson
algorithm we call it gomence williamson
even though michelle's name is is
michelle is belgian his name is
humans but we all call it gomez
williamson
um so here is here is how it goes so
this is this
commands sorry
commands williamson
algorithm
so what it says is let's identify
a vector in rn with with each
vertex um and and what we are really
looking for so we're going to have all
those all those vectors
and what we are hoping for is that
vertices that
um that that are joined by an edge
uh actually are very anti-correlated so
maybe one points the other way so all
those all those vectors will be unit
vectors
um and right so we'll have those
v i's and all of the vi's are going to
be unique
and and we hope that what we'll we'll
ask for is that the cross edges
will have as much anti-correlation as as
possible right so we're going to look at
the
the inner product of v i v j
when when i j is a is an
edge and we'll try at least on average
um
let's let's suppose that our edges are
just
all vertices are just numbers between
one and n
so for every edge on average over edges
we want this inner product to be to be
anti-correlated okay so we're going to
have lots and lots of um
so they're all supposed to be unit um
now there is this uh uh
trick we do right so so unit vectors
right so
right if you look at edges either you
have an edge or you don't have an
edge um right so so it either zero one
um but then the this this inner product
product
what we want is that right well well
um we want to count
we want kind of this this mapping right
so so this is
x f minus
x over 2 right math 1 to 0 and minus 1
to 1.
so really what we're going to consider
is is
half minus half of this
and and this will will tell us that when
we count how many edges
are separated
um then -1 is counted as plus one um
and and if it's a if it's a
if they are the same then it's going to
be counted as zero right so this is
this is what this uh this linear
transformation does for us okay so we'll
see a lot of like half minus half
of inner product right because this is
the way to translate between
between inner products and and just zero
one
okay so
so this is what we'll this is the
geometric problem we're going to
try to uh we're going to look at uh
we're
searching for unit vectors in rn
such that we want to maximize
um this this half minus half
sum of of the inner products i said
there's a question um
about the questions
questions and i think the comment is
just that the sum should be outside of
the
one sure yeah sure we can do we can make
it into
an average um okay
oh oh multiply everything by e yeah
okay thanks anyway so this is this is
the goldman sweet amazon algorithm
you want to solve max cut in in fact
instead
solve this this problem on finding unit
vectors
uh that try to be anti-correlated on
edges now
the nice thing about about this problem
this
geometric problem is that it has a an
efficient algorithm
um so so this is uh right this is known
as semi-definite programming
uh if you try to find vectors
and and all you have is is linear
constraints and linear objectives
on those on those pairwise inner
products um
then semi-definite programming is a
an efficient algorithm that solves this
problem
okay so so this is what government
williamson
algorithm does it
converted a combinatorial problem to a
geometric problem
and of course the vectors that the
algorithm may find
are not necessarily just would give you
plus one or minus one you can have all
kinds of
of angles between different vectors so
maybe you'll have
the i and v j and and the angle here
would be
would be general and and the question is
how do we how do we
um take this
and and get a cut out of that right so
so we have we got the vectors of the
algorithm
how do we have the cut and and what they
do so let me maybe switch a quarter so
what they do is they say
let's pick a random hackspace
um
so now pick
random half space
and then and then and then
partition then this induces the cut so
everything on one side
of this of this of this uh
on one side of the random half space is
going to get to be on one side of the
cut everything on the other side is
going to be on the other side of the cut
okay so so things that are very
anti-correlated
are not going to be on the on the same
side of the cut but but things that are
very very correlated unlikely to find
themselves in the same
on the same size side of the of the cut
okay so this is this is the algorithm so
there's a question
no question okay um
let's let's see if this is a
for for the geometers of you this is an
algorithm that
that makes sense right this is maybe
what you would
try to do and
okay so so how how good is it
um so so let's see so the probability
of separating
the probability to separate v i and v j
when the angle is between the misteta
what is set over
pi or to that over two pi um
and meanwhile what you pay for the in
the inner product
world half minus half
the the inner product right is f minus
half cosine
cosine cosine theta okay
so so right in the geometric world we
have
this in the in the in the maxcut world
we have this
and and then the question is what's
what's the ratio between them
um so maybe let me tell you here
mean the ratio between
set over pi and half minus half
cosine of theta this is
about eight seven eight
and this is the the the approximation
that goemon's williamson
gets okay so so you're going to
to get not the best cut but a cut that
is about 88
has about 88 of the the number of uh
of edges in the maximum cut okay which
is
you know pretty good um
if you're in the case where
in the special case well half minus half
cosine cosine theta is one minus delta
one minus delta
for very small delta you actually have
that theta over pi
oh man
let me maybe just say that say that
in the special case well well this
what you pay half minus half cosine
theta is very close to one
um is one minus delta the theta over pi
becomes 1 minus 2 over pi
square delta so so this is if
if you remember it's talk well she had 1
minus delta versus 1 minus square
delta this is well where it came from
anyway so i mean but this is it right
this is this is the whole government's
williamson
uh algorithm it gives 88
approximation ratio for max cut
um okay
start a new word um
and and for the geometric problem doing
this uh this
random half space this is the best you
can do
so this would this was a theorem of
fabian schertzmann
um random half space
is optimal
um
partition to cut the vectors
and and in the instance the graph that
they
they consider is this graph where you
have
um say all vectors on the sphere and and
you connect in an
edge uh to two vectors
that that um well the inner product is
some
fixed row um and
um and and you can see right so this is
as a perimetry that random half space is
the best
is the best cut um
the the the very surprising uh
theorem so this is this kkmo theom
that mentioned
quote kindle mozilla um
and and they showed that that
not only random half space is the best
thing to do in fact
this government williamson algorithm the
government's williamson algorithm
is is optimal
computationally
computationally for
max cut
as in as in it's np hard to do better
to approximate better
right and behind is uh right this is
what what we are able to
this is the notion of hardness we were
able to to
prove that it's as hard as
solving coloring efficiently
um at least this is true
if you assume this
the so-called evening games conjecture
okay so what i want to do is is prove to
you
at least sketch the proof of this uh of
this theorem
okay so so right it's it's a remarkable
theorem
um that that somehow this geometric very
simple geometric algorithm is
is is optimal um computationally right
you can't
it's np hard it's unlikely that that
um you'll be able to do better than than
this and and what's really remarkable is
that this is not just
about about max cut so
such a theorem is true for every
um for for every consent satisfaction
problem if you remember
the definition of those from its
lectures
um so uh
and it's a very interesting interesting
proof because what you
do is you take the optimality
of the geometric of the geometric
solution
like what we had fragger chechman
proving that that you can partition the
vectors better
than then taking a random
half space and and then you leave this
to to computational optimality
at least um
if you have this uni games conjecture
okay so so it's a direct a direct way
to lift optimality of
of in the geometry world
to optimality in the computational world
which is which is amazing and then
possible
actually generalized that and showed how
to do the same
same can be done
for all constraint satisfaction problems
so using geometric algorithm is not new
i mean it was new would
gomens and williamson did it in the
beginning of the 90s
before that there was linear programming
um
when instead of searching for vectors
research for four points
uh um points in r
and that satisfy some linear constraints
um you know trying to to satisfy some
something
objective um but
definitely since since gomez williamson
this has been
right what's in the toolbox of
algorithms people right any you give
them computational
uh you know combinatorial problems and
then they say oh but
let's let's embed it in in rn and let's
try to find vectors and and argue about
the
the the otherwise
correlations of them and and those
theorems
show that uh they will write algorithms
people
to to do this because indeed
it's a very good way to solve this is
like an optimal way to solve
um computational
optimization problems the computer
optimization problems just by by
reducing to
do geometry um and
it's really this uh the geometric
problem is basically equivalent to the
to the computational problem
okay which i mean it's mind-boggling
that you can
that this is true and that you can prove
that
okay so i'll be happy to answer any
questions
just about the the big picture
connection between geometry and
and computation and
if there are no such questions what what
i'll do is i want to remind you of this
uniqueness conjecture and then i i'll
sketch the proof of of this kkmo theorem
okay so
question the mapping tool
rn
not sure that i
so the the the mapping to rn right the
the
coming up with the vectors this is what
the semi-definite programming algorithm
does for you right what what you ask the
semi-definite program to do
is find for me unit vectors such that
you know as to maximize this uh linear
form in the pairwise correlations
and the magic is that is that um
this is possible to do efficiently
right
now i mean of course we can talk about
semi-definite programming and linear
programming and how those algorithms
work
and this is a fascinating topic
but not another topic that uh that i
have time to discuss right now
but but this is the amazing thing there
is a way you can tell an algorithm i
want vectors
like that and and please please find
them for me
um okay
okay good so so let me remind you of the
of the uni games conjecture
and the unique games conjecture talks
about this problem called unique label
cover
so this is a new combinatorial
optimization problem
it goes like that the input
is a graph
so in its lecture it was a bipartite
graph uh
for uni games it makes more sense to
have it not bipartite
um you also have an alphabet and usually
you denote
the size of the alphabet by k
this is some finite set of colors of
labels
and and then you also have uh
one to one permutations on the edges
right so you have those
pi e from sigma to sigma for every
edge okay and this is one to one
mappings and and the
the the goal you want to find the
labeling
of the vertices labeling
s of a from v to sigma
and it satisfies as many edges as
possible
um satisfies
as many edges as possible
and satisfies an edge
um this means
so let's say that the edge is uv in e
let's call it e um
what we want is that if you
see what what's the label that you get
and then the the mapping those
permutations give you what's the label
that you expect for v
and you want you want to get this this
uh you wanted the label to v would be
what
you expect
[Music]
okay so this is this is this unique
label cover
uh problem and then the uni games
conjecture
now i'm doing this first because
[Music]
you you redefined it on friday
uh so the new games conjecture so this
is quotes conjecture
from 2002 um
that for every epsilon and delta larger
than zero there exists k
k is a function of epsilon and delta
such that um
it is np hard
given a unique
label cover instance
input say
g sigma and sigma we usually get
we call the the number of uh labels k
and those pi e's um
to distinguish
between the two cases one is
all edges not all almost all
and
at least one minus delta fraction
of edges can be satisfied
versus at most
epsilon function
of edges
can be satisfied
okay so this is this is the unique games
conjecture the reason subash was
uh conjecturing that was that this is
known as a theorem
for a standard label cover right what we
call projection games
if the if the pi is weren't supposed to
be
[Music]
weren't wearing one to one um
then then this is true as a theorem
um in fact extremely strong
things on on right you can take you can
take delta equals zero and epsilon
uh depending on n going to zero
um we know that there are extremely good
reductions very efficient reductions
like that
um but but subhash was was bold enough
to
say this is true or this he hoped
would be true not just for normal level
cover but
for unique level cover all those
permutations on the edges were
well one-to-one functions
okay so this is this is the unique games
conjecture
again if there are any questions i'll be
very happy to to answer them
and and now what i want to do is is
prove to you
this this uh um kkmo but
first let's maybe have a picture in our
heads for
what's what's going on um
so over many many years uh beginning
i guess in the 80s and 90s um
formed this this paradigm for how to
prove uh
uh good uh you know proximability
results and it started
um with this basic pcp theorem so this
is
a theorem like we discussed in the in
the first and second lectures
um right well what do you say
basically you say it isn't hard to to
distinguish between the case that the
graph is three-colorable and a
graph is like far from fully colorable
um isn't unique have a question isn't
unique label cover a special case of
label cover
it is i'm confused how udc can be a
theorem when we don't
demand uniqueness while ugc itself
is a conjecture
no so so
so what i said is that right it is np
hard so so let's let's um maybe say
something about what it means
for something to be and be hard it means
that uh
there is this um there is a
construction a way to take
um you want to distinguish whether a
graph is pre-colorable not recordable
and then you can reduce it to
um to to a label cover
such that if the graph is recolorable
then the label cover is fully satisfied
and if the graph is not the color code
then the graph is far from
satisfied but
but this is true as a theorem in the
case of the the pi
is or not one to one um
in a in the sense that there is a
construction
well the the pi is not one to one and
then you can you can prove such a
reduction
and if you
require that the the paisa want one we
just don't have such a construction that
generates this sort of
this sort of instances um
okay maybe maybe the panelists would be
able to
to answer
okay yeah when we don't demand
uniqueness
this is known to be to be a theorem
um even with extremely good parameters
but when we demand
uniqueness we we don't know how to prove
it as a theorem
and okay so
good so so the way one proves optimally
in proximity results one starts with a
basic pcp theorem like what we discussed
in the first two layer
what if we described on friday
and get this label cover without
demanding uniqueness
and then there is a very nice paradigm
that i'll show you an example of
today uh based on something called the
long code
to get results like say the thrilling
result that rit kept mentioning um and
and
many many other other optimal and
approximately results
and so so this is the this is the the
basic paradigm
right i should mention the doll various
proof of the basic pcp theory and
they'll
one doesn't have to go for repetition
though other ways to go to label cover
and so on but but this this is the basic
scheme
and and what subas suggested now almost
20 years ago
was instead if we could go to unique
label cover right so demand uniqueness
demand one-to-one permutations in the
label cover
so this is what we don't know whether
this is true or not true
then we'll be able to do things
um like so so he gave all kinds of
examples
in his original paper the point is that
you can even
prove how much of results for problems
that look at two beats
um eventually max cut was proved this is
the kkm always all this is what i'll do
today
there is also a vertex cover is another
for those who know is another example
this was a
paper for dead regevin and subash and
many many other
theorems that you couldn't prove with
the standard paradigm
you can finally prove uh once you assume
this extra
extra implementations are unique
okay i see a question what is the best
many-to-one ratio known in the reduction
for
general level cover um
so so um
so you can actually get delta equals
zero
right in the instead of the unique games
conjecture for label cover you can get
delta
equals zero and and epsilon
that equals a one over poly logan
um yeah it's actually open whether you
can get
one over poly n for some for the right
polynomial
and okay so hopefully this
answers that so so we have extremely
good
good theorems like that in the case well
we don't demand one-to-one
but when we do demand we we have no idea
whether
how to do it or oh i mean we have some
ideas but not yet a proof
um but if we have the proof we can
we can uh use this this paradigm to
prove uh ultimate possibility for
problems like max cut
okay and it really i mean the reason
subash came up with this
question was that he knew very well what
was this
um transformation from label cover to
thrilling based on long code
and he just realized that everything
would be much much easier much much
simpler
if you could assume uniqueness um
it will just simplify everything and
we'll let you prove things that you
couldn't before
okay so so this is this is what i want
to do now
how does right so let me so i want to do
this
i want to do this and and talk about
long codes
so this is this is the plan i see a
question
um what is the weakest
instance of label cover still known to
be hard
uh with functions that are at most two
to one will still be hardness yes this
was proved
a couple of years ago if the functions
are just two to one
this was the the the
the two to two conjecture so this was
done
two years ago um
yeah the the one-to-one we still don't
have
um but we have various we have an
approach for how to do that we just
haven't
it hasn't uh yet
wasn't finalized yet okay
uh good so this is what what i'll do
what i'll do
next let me just give credit when
credit is due then this long code
paradigm that i'm going to present
it started with this work of er bellare
goldreich and
and and sudan and
and then johann hastad introduced free
analysis
um here and this completely
revolutionize everything let people
prove
optimal results and then and then i'll
do the k cable which is how to get
max cut from the unique games conjecture
okay good so let me
maybe define um
define the long code so for those of you
who listen to my
talk the second talk you may it may look
natural to you so this is long code
so suppose that we want to encode
some symbol in an alphabet
so what we'll do is um
we'll consider all the functions
we'll take all the functions from sigma
to
say plus minus one and
we'll
this would be done coding right so
instead of writing sigma
we're going to have a gigantic
and gigantic array that has for every
little function
f from sigma to plus one plus minus one
so every boolean function on sigma
put f of sigma okay and if you remember
the second talk there we had all the
quadratic functions
and now we'll just consider all possible
functions
and this is called the long code because
it is the longest binary code possible
so very without without repetitions so
all
possible linear combinations of the of
the input bits
are are not linear right all possible um
functions on the input bits are going to
be bits in the in the
encoding so this is the long code
okay so
good so now with that we have this
definition i can show you the reduction
so i want to show a reduction
from unique games
to maxcat
okay so i'm going to start with
right unique game so i have i have a
graph with with you know some alphabet
all the labels on the vertices and some
permutations
and i want to generate from that a max
cut instance
so some other graph and
and and well i'm searching for the max
cut
okay so so the the convention look so
i'll consider
suppose that um the unique games
instance
uh let's say that this is given by g and
sigma
and and pi e and max cut will just
describe
directly what are the what are the
vertices and what are the edges
okay so
so max cut
vertices right so i just i just need to
define for you a
graph that's it all right so so the
vertices
are going to be um for
every for every
vertex in in
um in v well this is
right g is v e so for every vertex
of the the unique game
and i'm going to have a
vertex of the max card but also for
every
i need two edges
u and v
and you prime v and e
right so in the unique game you have v
you have u and u prime these are two
two vertices that are that are neighbors
of v and
and therefore the labels induced labels
for for v
um and also for every
function f from sigma
to plus minus one
um i'm going to have oh
just a sec this is going to come a bit
later
let me
so for every f and for every function
sigma 2 plus minus 1
i'm going to have a vertex
that i'll denote denoted
um f of
sigma v okay so so
really what i want to do is is have an
encoding a long code encoding
of the label of of v so the u and the u
prime will come
in the second when i when i describe the
edges i i got
um okay let's
we'll do that in a second um right so so
for every
for every vertex so so i have a vertex v
of the
of the uni game and then there is some
label
sigma v uh that that it's supposed to
get
so label in the alphabet it's supposed
to get
and and i'm trying to encode this label
right so so i'm introducing uh right and
call it with the long chord so for every
f
like this i have i have a vertex that
corresponds to
um that is supposed to be applying this
function on this one label that is
that is supposed to be for v okay so
these are these are my vertices okay for
every v
i have like a block of many many
many many uh possible um
possible many many vertices and all of
them together correspond to the
to the um to then
uh supposed encoding of of the label of
v
okay and remember that in max car the
the
the solution right what we ask the
algorithm to do is to to
find the car find a partition of the
vertices into two
right so for each for each one of those
vertex
vertices it will tell it to it'll be on
one side of the cut or the other side of
the cut it will give it some boolean
value
and this boolean value is supposed to be
f
of the label of v
so these are these are the vertices
now as to the edges
so so let me let me use the the
same convention that i had before i'm
going to show you how to pick
a random pick a random edge
um
okay so here is how you pick a random
edge
you take v then you take this u and u
prime
so so pick um
u v in e and then u prime
then e so so two
two uh random edges
that touch on on v
um and also pick f
and also uh we're going to pick
uh some noise to apply on on on f
okay so so the noise so i'm going to
denote it
as quickly f so squiggly f
of sigma for every sigma
is quickly f sigma will be
f of sigma with probability
um half plus
row over two what would be our parameter
and minus f of sigma with the remaining
with
probability one minus this
okay um and then the
edge let me erase this
so the edge would be um
so the edge is going to be between
what's called f of
pi e sigma u
and f of
pi e prime this e
and e prime
sigma uh
okay this is kind of a bit much too
now but let me kind of break it down for
you
right so what i want right an edge means
that i want those two endpoints to have
different boolean assignments okay
okay good so let's let's try to to see
what's going on
here but i mean this is it this is the
whole construction
um so what i
ask uh there is supposed to be you is
supposed to get some assignment
which which i denote sigma u it's not
clear that this assignment actually
exists but but in the good case uh well
there is a good um assignment to the uni
games there is some
some for every use some stigma you
same for your point or sigma u prime
that that are
uh that satisfy many of the edges uh of
the
of the uni game and so in each one so
sigma u
um gives some value
for for v so this is what i call pi e of
sigma u
let me switch to a pointer right so so
sigma u is is the
is the value i'm supposed to get the
label that is supposed to be for u
sigma you find the the label suppose
that supposedly the label that your
prime gets
the label that you get induces some
label that
we supposed to get the label of u prime
induces through
pi e prime the label that
b is supposed to get according to u
prime and
sorry i that's minus here
and squiggly um
and right so so f of
uh right so this and this are supposed
to be the same
and if they are the same they are the
same when you apply the same function on
them
so so they're supposed to be the same
which means that if you look at this
and and minus f they're supposed to be
different
um and i'm adding this
squiggly which is kind of checking this
robust version
of this and
this should be true even if i change the
function a little
uh which which is not supposed to to
change much with with high probability
and okay yeah so
this is a lot to to digest
if this is the first time that that you
see all of this
but this is the construction i'm happy
to
[Music]
um have 10 minutes so
in the interest of time i want i won't
repeat this this
explanation right but maybe
right this and this all supposed to be
the same in the
right if the uni game thing is is the
same so so f
applied on both is supposed to be the
same so
so f and minus f are supposed to be
different
and squiggly should
is is not yeah doesn't change much
if if if if f squiggly is the same as f
with good probability okay
i'm i'm running out of time
so this is this is the construction
um wow
i have very very little time left
okay so i want to sketch for you uh
the the proof why why this this
reduction works
um questions
the edge is there if that condition
holds
another otherwise in no no the edge
the edge is here
the edge is here always between the the
vertex that is labeled this way
and the vertex that is labeled this way
um okay and if
if there are if there are ways if there
are sigma used that are good
then then the the right it all makes
sense and if they'll not it it makes
lessons
uh more questions uh will one side of
the cut have all satisfied
edges up to noise and the other all
answer
no no so this is
right an edge an edge means that
that uh right they have different on
different sides of the cut
right so in the good case um
most of the edges are on different sides
of the cut
okay there is inequality between those
assignments
maybe i'll i'll just uh wow
i i won't actually have time to
do much um but let me
maybe go back here so i'm right i
described to you this
this reduction i haven't i haven't
analyzed it
yeah i could analyze it if i had
10 more minutes um it's
actually uh the the interesting thing
about the analysis
is that it relies on gaussian
isoparametry
right so so the
so the the understanding
is that when we check this
right so you can look at all the all the
all the vertices that end up on one side
of the
of the cut right
and you can think of this as a as a set
and and here the number of of edges that
that that cross the cut is exactly the
surface area
of of this of this set
um and saying that right um
right and this this is a set of
function about half um
okay uh so so
the the the interesting thing is that
the analysis here for why this
construction works
uh uh just just follows from um
from from gaussian iso elementary there
is a nice dom that shows that
um this right so the construction was
purely on on the boolean hyper cube
um but it turns out that that the
quantities that we analyze
without loss of generality we can
analyze them um
is in gaussian space
and and and the analysis completely
follows from
from um this and from from gaussian
isoparimetry
um yeah so somehow
gaussian isopronometry gave us this
reduction that we were
looking for uh and had i
had even more time
i would have told you right so so the
interesting thing here
is that right so so focusing ability of
max cut
which is a computational problem
which lives in computational world
is basically equivalent um to
to gaussian isopremetry um
right both the governments williamson al
algorithm
is an algorithm that uses gaussian as a
polymetry to partition those
those vectors and and also the gaussian
isoplametry is what proves
optimality right and this is kind of in
leaves in german geometric world
donna can i ask you a quick question
yeah are you claiming that you can
derive gaussian iso perimetry from
approximate in the proximality of max
cut or approximability of max code
so what i said was that we prove in
approximate value of max cut
from gaussian isopodium right but your
arrow here goes the other way too
no so this is because the gaussian
isoforadometry gives us the best
algorithm and optimality of gas and
isoparametry gives us
the optimality of the approximation
algorithm so in this sense
right thanks i now understand the double
error all right
okay maybe maybe it would be i mean
maybe it would be worth it to take like
an extra you know
five ten minutes just to give it a
little bit more of a flavor yeah
so so what i'm thinking is that i can
kind of talk a bit about the the high
level picture
for the few minutes that i have left
until 12
and until my 12th um
and and then i'll i want to do my
my original plan which is to actually
show you the the analysis and the
connection to isoprometry and whoever
wants to
to stay for that can stay for that and
it will be another
10 15 minutes at the most okay but but i
want to
write let's talk a bit about the the
high level picture
so somehow approximation for max cut is
is completely
um is is completely given by by gaussian
isoparimetry
um both the algorithm and the hardness
which is
very remarkable because one lives in
computational world and the other lives
in geometric world
this is true only assuming the ugc
for now the unique games conjecture it's
a conjecture right it's like
this this part here that we don't know
how to prove for now
um there is another interesting point i
wanted to make
is that um still this
this this sort of reductions are
interesting
uh just from uh the geometric
perspective
so um in the in the time i
i don't have but i'll take i
i wanted to also mention uh that
right you can continue living in right
if even if you don't assume the
ugc even if you don't care about the
geometric world
just in in geometry world right this is
an interesting
this is an interesting thing that you
have a reduction
from one problem to another
uh and and this sort of reduction was
used
uh to show that that l2 squared
uh cannot be embedded uh with constant
distortion in l1
um l2 squared with with uh as a metric
with assuming that it satisfies the
triangular inequality
um and and this was just pulled by
by taking uh kind of the
the proof right looking at the geometric
problem that is associated here
um and and seeing
um an improving optimality here
and then using this sort of reductions
so there it's not max cut it's a related
problem called spouse's cut
um and and getting something healed and
then this process cut is basically
equivalent to this
l2 square to l1 embeddability um
right so so even if you continue if you
just engine in the geometric world you
don't need the utc
you can actually get very interesting
results
just from from this sort of stuff
okay so so this is this is the plan for
the the 15 minutes extra that i'm going
to take
i'll describe to you this i'll show you
the analysis of this
and then and then i'll talk to you about
this non-embeddability result
okay good so i've
so there is this gather town and whoever
wants to
stop now can stop now but
um yeah whoever wants to
to see this analysis
um of
unique games to max cut
reduction
i'm going to describe that okay so so i
mean let me
let me kind of first switch to more uh
familiar
uh terms and and i'll do
this um for every
okay so for every vertex
in the unit game really what i have
is a is a function let me denote it fv
it's a function from plus minus 1 to the
k
2 plus minus 1 so so
let's see what we had before this is the
construction as we had before so this is
a bit of a cumbersome
notation so so i want to kind of present
this in a more familiar way
um right so it's really right so i have
the
all those all those uh right
i'm supposedly evaluating
all possible functions on the supposed
label
of the vertex okay
now notice
notice that that the function
f from sigma to plus -1
is exactly equivalent to a vector
that has here all the sigmas
and here has f of sigma right so this is
the the truth table right i can identify
a function with its truth table
it's the it's the same thing right
and and really what what i
um what what i want this long quote
encoding
i want i i kind of tell the
the person finding the the labels well
there is some label that you're trying
to encode the label to this
to this vertex um so
i just want you to every every function
just give me what what the function does
on on uh sigma right this was my
definition of the long code
right for every function so for every
vector
just tell me what what how it evaluates
on on the label
that you think that this vertex is uh
supposed to get
okay so so such functions
are known as as dictators so this is a
right supposedly long code is
the same as
what we call a dictator
so supposedly we take right we take
f and we give f of sigma
and we can think of it as right it's a
function f v
right x takes this vector and gives
um it gives this
the sigma location
right so so so this is the this is the
long code
okay um
right every function is supposed to give
them you get the evaluation on sigma
it's the same as
right the function is given by the truth
table you just want one location from
this truth table
okay um so so right
so this is what's what's a kind of i
prescribe
this is what i prescribe this is what i
ask a kind of the the the labeler to do
or the the the algorithm for max cut
for every right so for every
for every v give me give me
for every f give me f of of the
assignment to the label of
to v but in fact
the the the algorithm may not give me
a dictator it may give me a general
function a general boolean function okay
so so this is this is uh
this is what the
what the the we ask the the algorithm
what the cut algorithm is expected to do
right so so this is for
take the the actual label sigma v for v
and and tell me for every function
what's the evaluation of the function on
on
on this label um
right which corresponds to this dictator
function that takes a
function and just gives you one location
in the truth table
uh but but then there is what the what
the
what the algorithm what the the
algorithm
may do what the cut
um gives it gives some boolean function
right because the cut is some boolean
function on the vertices
right so for every v for every
right each f is like is like a vector
like this
it's always each f is a vector like this
and and it gives it some boolean value
okay
um okay
good so so let's just write in in with
this terminology so
right yeah every time one
um does this uh flip
right it's kind of hard to to continue
following online but the hope is that
it's recorded so
um uh it's possible to
kind of pause and understand kind of
this uh
conceptual uh step that we just made
um right so the situation is
i have my my uni game right so i have
all those
vertices
and and in the max cut each each vertex
is is replaced with with a bunch of
with with many other vertices that
represent an encoding of
it and you can think
of the of the labeling to those vertices
as
as a function fv
um right so for every v the
the you have those new vertices and you
have this new function
fv that is supposed to encode an
assignment to v
if fv were a dictator it would have
encoded an assignment
to v but but otherwise
i mean it's some it's some function okay
so so with this notation
um let me let me try to write
what what what's the test that we do
um so the test that we do
we can write say the probability that
the test accepts
um right so so really what we
okay yeah it's a bit um
the the important term here is that we
look at fv
of f and fv
of f squiggly and
for random f um
and and we ask what's the correlation
between
between those two functions once when we
apply it on on f and once when we apply
it
oh sorry let me
make one more definition
before i do this let's define
fv as follows um
fv of f it
takes a random edge u v and
e
let's call it e and then
it looks at the vertex
that
is this is its name right so so we
so we take a random neighbor v call it u
um and then there is supposed to be some
label for u and then the label for mu
for you is induces some label for v
and then we want to evaluate
evaluate in f
on that label so this is what we're
trying to do
and then we can write the probability
that and all the the fraction of edges
cut
we can write it as half minus
f sigma v
e
f v f f b
f squiggly
okay um so this
is right so this is how we defined edges
we looked at
at f and we looked at a squiggly f
and right one comes from some u and the
other comes from
some u prime and
and right and and
right in the in the language right so we
could have written it in the in the
language of how many edges are cut and
and this is how it's written in
in the language of a correlation uh
between between the functions
and then this actually
looks much more familiar
[Music]
right because really what what we check
here
is what's the noise stability right so
this term here
is the noise stability
of fv
so this is what we achieved with with
the
construction i showed you that the
fraction of edges cut
is is exactly exactly relates to the
noise stability
of um of the
the this function that we get
okay so this is how isopolymetry
comes in okay
let me write down the analysis
um just for completeness
um okay so
if if
um the fraction of edges cut
is at least
cosine rho
divided by pi plus epsilon which is kind
of if you do this calculation of
of commons williamson right this is what
we are trying to
to prove that if this happens then
uh the the those fv's must be
in some way a dictator right so this is
what we're trying to do
many edges cut if there is a lot of
noise stability of those fvs
then those fvs must be kind of like
dictators
and and because they're kind of like
dictators they actually correspond to a
labeling for the unique game
so this is this is what we're trying to
prove
um so just by by averaging
and then for at least
epsilon over two fraction of the v
we get let me call it asterix
that squiggly
fvf fv
squiggly f here
is at most 1 minus 2 over pi
r cosine cosine of y
minus epsilon
okay so so right if many many edges
are cut then for many for many of those
of those right by averaging many of
those vertices we get
a noise stable and
we get noise stable um
this should be noise stable right it
should be the other way
we get noise noise stable uh functions
um okay
now the interesting thing
so the analysis proceeds in in two steps
one is what we call the invariance
principle so this was
beautiful theorem by
mozello don elena kevitz
that says that
this expression the noise stability
when f is over the boolean hypercube
plus minus 1 to the k to plus minus 1
this is the same as
if you evaluated it in gaussian
space um
sorry
f and plus minus 1 to the k this is the
same as f is gaussian
and the same expression
well the squiggly becomes gaussian
noise
and then we can use a gaussian
isopronometry so this is a theorem of
well
to say well i mean it just it just
this is impossible you don't have
functions that are
oh i'm sorry the the the this is true
um if
the influence of every
every index on the function
under the grid part of the function is
always small then you have this
if all the influences if if we have a
function where all the influences are
small then then the situation in the
in the uh the brilliant hypercube is the
same as the situation of a gaussian
um but but then right and
and the issue is that over gaussian it
can't be um
so godzilla is a polymetry tells us that
that uh
um that asterisks cannot happen
in gaussian world
gaussian right so
right combining the two the only way
that that asterisks can happen
uh is if there exists uh some sigma
in in sigma that that um
right there exists some something here
where the influence is large and this is
going to be the label
that we're going to um we're going to
associate with
with v um right so so
hence asterix
implies some sigma some
with large influence
which this would be
this would be the label to be
this is the this is the analysis i see
that i have some questions or no
questions were answered this is it
um right with i mean this is at least
the sketch
of uh of the this
kkmo and moo analysis
of the construction i mean so really
what it is saying
is that when i define for you this kind
of weird
construction really what i did is
is make the max cut problem into this
isoparametric
problem on those functions associated
with
with each vertex
and and what we showed
here was that if i have
many edges cut it must be
because because
this function is actually associated
with with a
dictator okay i have a lot more to say
about the inverse principle and stuff
but
i won't say it for now because i'm
running out of time
um yeah so this is what i wanted to say
about this sorry
right about this part um
right so so how how max cut is really
all about
gaussian isopronometry um
i could tell you about this
non-embeddability of
l2 squared in l1 but maybe the panelists
can
can tell me i i mean i'm already i
already took the 15 minutes
um maybe maybe i can stop here because
okay there's another talk soon okay
good so so this is it for today
okay but is there a quick question that
we can take
okay i guess we can all start this again
uh with the video in
at a lower lower uh lower pace
um thank the enough for for the lecture
and we will come back
in 10 30 there is a 11 minute break
you can help in the gather time thanks
daniel
thanks dana